what is the nth number in the following
sequence let's see the first term here
is a six so over here I'll put the term
so this is the number this is the number
I'll just write numb there that's the
number and this is the term this is the
term so the first term here is a six
that looks like we add 3 to that to get
to a 9 well maybe there's some other
pattern here so that's the second term
is 9 then they go from 9 to 12 it looks
like we add 3 again so we keep adding 3
so the third term is 12 the fourth term
is 15 and we need to think of a general
expression that will give us the value
of the nth term the nth number in the
following sequence so let's think a
little bit about it we know that we're
incrementing by 3 every time and we're
starting at 6
so let's write these in terms of
multiples of 3 since we know that that's
the increment level this is this first
term right here is 3 times 2 the second
term right here is 3 times 3 this third
term is 3 times 4 and so it looks like
it's 3 times 1 more than the actual term
you are dealing with right here if you
take your term you add 1 and then
multiply that by 3 you get 6 take your
term add 1 then multiply it by 3
take your term add 1 you get 4 then
multiply by 3 take your term add 1 which
would be 5 and then multiplied by 3 you
get 15 so it looks like anytime so if
you have your nth term so if you go all
the way out here to your nth term the
value here would be you'd add 1 to it so
you'd have n plus 1 and then you would
multiply that by 3 so the nth term is 3
times n plus 1 or if you wanted to
distribute out the 3 it would be 3 and
plus 3 and just make sure that works for
all of them the first term 3 times 1 is
3 plus 3 that works that's 6 the second
term 3 times 2 plus 3 is 9 so it works
for all of these terms so that is the
instrument have to assumed that this
pattern continues